narcissism is one of the most
misunderstood terms of our time we are
so aware of the bad narcissist one whose
overweening Pride leaves them no room
for empathy or kindness that we are at
risk of missing the central role that
narcissism should play in the
development of any healthy human
none of us is able to thrive without a
chance to deeply like ourselves a
Psychotherapy recognizes we universally
require a dose of what is termed healthy
narcissism a sense of our lovability and
rightful place in the world bequeathed
to us via the approbation of kindly and
enthusiastic caregivers in our early
years
in our haste to condemn selfishness and
pride we miss out on the primordial
importance of self-esteem and confidence
generated by love
if we analyze his situation from a
clinical point of view the mythological
narcissus didn't get fixated on his
reflection to the exclusion of others
because he loved himself too much a good
deal more poignantly he did so because
some form of early deprivation must have
bread in him a need to manically keep
checking in on himself in a doomed
search for a value he clearly couldn't
believe in without adequate approval we
develop what is known as a narcissistic
wound a feeling of profound inadequacy
in relation to elements like our looks
our status or our intelligence as
wounded people we will then keep being
drawn despite ourselves to scenarios
that scratch at our perceived flaws will
be alive to every criticism about us
we'll pick Partners who can't reassure
us and will anticipate and thereby often
precipitate the end of everything
positive or kind
we hear too much about a character who
grows evil and selfish because they
think too well of themselves the reality
is far more complex and sad everyone
needs to be adored and will suffer
immensely if they are not we should
strive to become more conscious of our
narcissistic wounds and try to solve
them through intense doses of the very
same sort of Love whose original absence
created them
as we need to keep reminding ourselves
no one ever grew ill from too much love